Das Podcast-Ofo mit Florian Will und Stefan Tietze.
Nee, Moment, die, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, mit dem Willenbemfang, das Podcast UFO, bezeichnet uns den Dinosauriern.
Das Podcast UFO, mit Florentin Bill und Stefan Titte. Titte, Titte, Titte, Titte. Tietze, schönen guten Tag, wie schön. Guten Tag, herzlich willkommen zu Podcast UFO, Podcast, ich bin völlig überall wichtig, für dem Podampo-Podcast mit Mo Flitz. Ich habe gerade gesagt, er hat nämlich gesagt im Intro mit Dinosauriern, und das klingt wie unser Sidekick Jan. Ja, Dinosauriern. Dinosaurian. Eigentlich ein sehr guter Sidekick, der die ganze Zeit schon unterm Tisch sitzt und eines Tages rauskommt als Dinosaurian. Dinosaurian. Das war Mo Flitz. Mo Flitz? Mir gegenüber sitzt Stefan Tietze, das habt ihr jetzt gehört. Ich finde es immer noch verrückt. Und Florian Witt kennt ihr hinlänglich bekannt. Ich glaube wirklich, also ich kenne dich jetzt schon eine ganze Weile und ich glaube, ich habe noch nie jemanden, dich Stefan Tietze nennen hören. Es ist immer nur der Titzmeister, der Titzler, irgendwie Itzi Bitsi Tizzi. Es ist nie Stefan Tietze. Das ist so Stefan meistens. Stefan. Stefan mit einem fordernden Ton erstmal. Gibst du mir mal die Trinkflasche, Stefan? Warum sind die Leute so genervt mit dir direkt? Hast du da mal drüber nachgegangen? Weil ich immer zu gut gelaunt durch die Welt laufe und die Leute sind schnell ein bisschen genervt von dieser positiven Energie. Stefan! Stefan! Stefan! Es ist auch so ein Name, der einlädt das so zu sagen. Es ist jetzt nicht so ein liebevoller Stefan, der kleine Stefan. Es gibt auch Namen, die kann man gut rufen und Namen, die kann man nicht gut rufen. Also ich würde immer, wenn man sich überlegt, wie soll mein Kind heissen, wenn es verloren geht und im Wald gerufen werden muss, dann braucht es einen guten Namen und nicht irgendwie so Ulf oder sowas. Ulf, Ulf, Ulf, Ulf, Ulf, Ulf, Ulf, Ulf, ich denke mir, wenn man mit so einer Hundestaffel unter dem ganzen Dorf mit so Stöcken durchs Unterholz geht, will man dann nach einem Ulf rufen, nein, Ulf, Ulf, Ulf, Ulf, Ulf, Ulf, Ulf, Ulf, Ulf, Ulf, Ulf, Ulf, Ulf, Ulf, Ulf, Ulf, Ulf, Ulf, Ulf, Ulf, Ulf, Ulf, Ulf, Ulf, Ulf, Ulf, Ulf, Ulf, Ulf, Ulf, Ulf, Ulf, Ulf, Ulf, Ulf, Ulf, Ulf, Ulf, Ulf, Ulf, Ulf, Ulf, Ulf, Ulf, Ulf, Ulf, Ulf, Ulf, Ulf, Ulf, Ulf, Ulf, Ulf, Ulf, Ulf, Ulf, Ulf, Ulf, Ulf, Ulf, Ulf, Ulf, Ulf, Ulf, Ulf, Ulf, Ulf, Ulf, Ulf, Ulf, Ulf, Ulf, Ulf, Ulf, Ulf, Ulf, Ulf, Ulf, Ulf, Ulf, Ulf, Ulf, Ulf, Ulf, Ulf, Ulf, Ulf, Ulf, Ulf, Ulf, Ulf, Ulf, Ulf, Ulf, Ulf, Ulf, Ulf, Ulf, Ulf, Ulf, Ulf, Ulf, Ulf, Ulf, Ulf, Ulf, Ulf, Ulf, Ulf, Ulf, Ulf, Ulf, Ulf, Ulf ein gutes Bild, was man sich vorstellen sollte, wenn man über Kindern Namen spricht, wie man sich generell die Situation vorstellt, wie sehr viele hundert Leute, hundert Schafpolizei mit Spielhunden und diesen Stöcken im Unterholz. Joachim! Und dann ist einer aus dem Dorf dabei, der viel zu doll mit diesen Stöcken ins Unterholz hauft. Oh, vor allem, ich glaube, von dem kommen die Stöcke, weil wer hat die ganzen Stöcke zu Hause? Ich glaube, der denkt, da wird gesucht, dann macht er seine Garage auf mit tausenden Stöcken, verteilt die und dann... Wir reden, wenn Kinder verschwunden sind oder Frauen vermisst sind, Jungs vermisst sind, dann macht man das ja. Und ich finde es immer nur lustig, die Vorstellung, dass es so beginnt, diese Suchstaffel, wie jemand dann da so sitzt und seinen Stock anspitzt. Und dann geht so langsam die Saluntür auf. Und man denkt so, warum will er den anspitzen? Wir brauchen dich, den besten Speerstecher des ganzen Wilden Westens. Er findet die Kinder. Wer ist noch dabei? Ein Tempik gesagt, ich bin raus. Temi Demi ist dabei. Ich bin zu alt für den Job und mit dem mache ich das nicht. Temi Demi ist dabei. Entweder Temi Demi oder ich. Es gibt in dieser Suchstaffel nur Platz für einen Stochstecher. Weisst du, was man über dich sagt? Was? Du findest jedes Kind, aber tot. Tot oder lebendig steht meistens drauf. Es macht aber einen Unterschied, ob tot oder lebendig. Na ja, wenn da steht tot oder lebendig, scheint es ja nicht so ein grosser Unterschied zu sein. Na, es ist trotzdem schon noch ein Unterschied. Ich steche da rein, aber dafür finde ich's. Meine Suchquote ist 100%. Wie so eine Harpune, wo man dann einfach so zack und dann das Kind rauszieht und ich hab's gefunden. Ich hab's gefunden, aber es geht nicht darum, es zu finden, es geht darum, es lebendig zu bärten. Es geht darum, dass es sich selbst findet. Selbstfindung. Ihr wundert euch, warum meine Haare nass sind. Nicht gewundert, ehrlich gesagt. Zu Recht. Ich hab von dir schon so viele schillernde Frisuren gesehen, dass mich mittlerweile gar nichts mehr wundert. Du denkst, es ist so ein Wet-Look-Wax. In alle Richtungen, ja. Nee, es ist tatsächlich einfach nass geworden, weil wir nehmen, wie ihr, wenn ihr uns bei Patreon folgt und im UFO-Club seid, im illustren, exklusiven Podcast-UFO-UFO-Club, dann seht ihr uns ja gerade und dann wundert ihr euch, was hat Stefan da auf seinem Kopf gemacht, ist das, ach du Schande, nee, es ist einfach nur nass geworden, weil wir sind in Stefan wohl in der Hansestadt Hamburg am Hafen und hat da ein bisschen den Jet-Ski-Fahrern beim Umspritzen zugesehen und ist dann ein bisschen zu nah herangetreten? Ich bin wie Icarus zu nah an Jet-Skis herangelaufen. Genau, ja. Also eigentlich eins zu eins. Das ist die alte Lektion, das ist die alte Lektion. Ja, ich bin viel zu nah herangedackelt und dann dachte ich mir, was ist das denn das Motorrad auf dem Wasser? Was ist das denn? Was was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, wollte und die gesagt haben, wir machen das einfach so. Das ist wie so dieses, du hast das kleine Schiff, um es mal mit hamburgerischem Vergleich zu erzählen, du hast das kleine Schiff, das zieht das grosse Schiff. Ja. Und irgendwann sagt das sagt das kleine schiff alter ja fuck it alle wollen nur noch das kleine schiff sein und niemand will mehr das grosse schiff sein und irgendwann fahren die leute nur noch kleine schiffe ich glaube jetzkis haben den namen woanders her ich glaube die wurden von einem polen erfunden pavlov jetzky jetzky ist ein sehr ernster ingenieur pavlo ernster Ingenieur, der versucht hat, das Problem des Wassertransports zu lösen, weil natürlich in Polen es gibt viele Kanäle, wo die nicht drüber kommen und dann, Pawlow Czecki, wir sind durchs ganze Land gereist, um sie zu treffen, aus Griechenland, wir sind aus Griechenland oder wo auch immer hergekommen, Ehrlich gekommen. Wir sind schon so lange unterwegs, dass wir alle Sprachen und Akzente der Welt aufgesogen haben. Pavlovdschetsky! Ist fertig. Ist fertig, Wasserfahrgerät ist fertig. Wasser, das ist genau, was wir brauchen. Ist was ihr braucht fahrt da über die Flüsse, fahrt über Gewässer, Wasser nicht länger dein Problem, Wasser nicht länger das Element, das zu fürchten du gelernt hast. Mein Name ist Jetski, das Fun steht für Spass. Das ist ein alter Freestyle-Rap-Instinkt, wie so ein Fluchtriss-Instinkt, schön zurück zu Pfeffer und Salz. Ich habe einen Jetski-Führerschein, ist ja in meinem Bootsführerschein mit drin. Den kriegt man einfach so da mit reingeschmissen. Der ist da mit drin. Das ist wie so Flyer, wie so Werbung. Ja. So ein Gutschein, den du daneben auch einfach noch mitkriegst und den eigentlich gar niemand will. Und Funfact, man darf den Jetski nur 60 Minuten lang in eine Richtung bewegen. Weil sonst die Erddrehung nur unruhegebracht wird, oder was? Jetski, Jetski, gibt es irgendwelche Sachen, die wir bedenken müssen? Also es ist kein Spassgerät, es darf nur verwendet werden, um von Kanalseite A zu Kanalseite B zu kommen. Und es fährt mit Plutonium. Rein symbolischen Plutonium. Aber nicht zu schnell und zu lang fahren, sonst ist die Erdrotation. Nein, die Erdrotation Goros ist Boom. Es sei denn, ihr habt einen zweiten Jetskifahrer, der in der gleichen Situation in die andere Richtung auffällt. Aber beachtet Magnetfeld der Erde, beachtet das Magnetfeld. Ja, es reagiert sehr empfindlich. Ist das eigentlich völlig okay, diesen Akzent einfach nachzumachen. Gut, ich meine, wir wollen jetzt nicht über den späten Pavlov-Jetski sprechen, sondern über seine Hochphase. Was er danach noch getan hat, darüber wollen wir gar nicht reden. Das weiss nur der liebe Gott. Das liegt jetzt in Gottes Händen. Naja, nee. Okay, du hast eine christliche Phase gerade. Kann das sein? Ich erwische dich oft beim Beten. Ich komme dann rein in den Raum und Stefan betet zum Podcast Gott, zum Podcast Heiligen, zum Heiligen Sankt Felix. Ja, heute Morgen habe ich auch so ein bisschen vom Feiern noch müde gewesen, nicht feiern, aber lange wach gewesen, müde gewesen, schön den Fernseher angemacht und da lief eine Messe. Und ich habe gar nicht daran gedacht, das umzuschalten. Ich habe nicht im geringsten daran gedacht, das jetzt wegzuschalten. Keine Phase in dir hat gesagt, weg damit! Kein Hautpartikelchen hat gesagt, weg mit diesem Sender. Nein, ich fand das total beruhigend morgens so ein bisschen. Und es war so eine festliche Messe, erkennt man daran, dass alles gesungen wird. Dieses Gebet. Liebe Gemeinde, heute sind wir zusammengekommen. Ich bin Pfarrer Matthäus, das M steht für Messe, Messdiener. Alles ist besser mit Beatbox, alles ist besser mit Beatbox und ich glaube, ich werde jetzt Beatboxen lernen, also noch besser, aber ich glaube, es ist einfach die beste Möglichkeit und ich glaube, es ist auch ideal für lange Autofahrten, wenn du lange mit jemandem im Auto bist, einfach zu sagen, hey, ich könnte für euch ein bisschen Beatboxen. Ähm, nee, alles gut, dankeschön, ich spiele aber eh hier Switch. Achso, nee, gut, kannst du ja nebenbei noch hören, weil ich würde einfach, ich habe so ein Set. Nee, weil ich hier bei Blablaka habe ich ja angegeben, Stille, einfach nur. Nee, du hast, nee, nein, nein, nein. Die krasseste Stille, man kann wirklich ein Haarfallen hören im Auto, habe ich gesagt. Ich habe hier nochmal geguckt, du hast nur gesagt, keine Gespräche. Das Beatbox-Feld hast du leer gelassen und deswegen bin ich das gibt es, das ist Anmerkungen. Muss ich da explizit, Beatbox ausschliessen? Ja, aber der Algorithmus hat jetzt... Ich habe auch nicht ausgeschlossen, dass du mich mit Bananen bewirbst, zum Beispiel. Die habe ich zum Essen mitgenommen. Ich meine nur... Dachtest du jetzt, ich werde nicht anfangen, mit Bananen zu machen? Nein, ich meine nur, als Beispiel... Ich habe 16 Bananen dabei für eine zweieinhalb stündige Fahrt. Das ist eine ganz normale Menge Bananen. Nein, das ist ein bisschen viel. Wenn du eine willst, dann sagst doch. Aber du musst doch jetzt nicht mit einem Vorwurf rankommen. Ich wollte nicht mit einem Vorwurf rankommen, ich wollte nur sagen, ich kann ja nicht explizit alles ausschliessen, was du machen könntest. Aber der Algorithmus hat doch mich extra dir zugewiesen, weil normalerweise die Leute Beatbox immer ausschliessen, du hast es jetzt nicht angekreuzt, weder ja noch nein, also hat mich derjenige aufgenommen, damit ich Beatboxen kann. So, ich hätte ein 40-minütiges Set mit verschiedenen Tracks, verschiedenen Rhythmen, verschiedenen Geschwindigkeiten und danach können wir gucken, wie machen wir weiter. Ich habe dann noch so das in der Sommeredition, ich habe das noch in so einem Winter-Beatbox. Ah, okay, die Kehlkopf-Version hast du auch noch? Die Kehlkopfgesang, die Nepal-Palinesische. Ja. Das ist nicht so schlecht. Hat schon jemals jemand Beatbox gehört und gesagt, ah ja, das war eine gute Verwendung meiner Freizeit. Das, äh, ich bin ganz merkwürdiger Skill. Gibt es auf Spotify so wirkliche Beatbox-Playlists Alben, wo man wirklich sagt, geil, jetzt einfach mal zwei Stunden lang durch Beatboxen? Weil das Beatbox-Problem ist halt so ein bisschen... Ich verstehe das Wort auch nicht, bin ich ehrlich. Beatbox. Naja, das ist halt, wenn du keine Musikinstrumente dabei hast, wenn du deine Laute zu Hause vergessen hast und trotzdem
Freestyle und Rappen willst und ein paar Lines niederlegen willst,
dass du dann jemanden hast, der dann so ein bisschen
Rhythmus gibt. Und daraus ist diese Kunstform entstanden,
als eine der vier Säulen von Hip-Hop.
Die vier Säulen von Hip-Hop sind
Rap,
Graffiti,
Breakdance, Skaten
oder so, Beat,
ich finde gut, dass Beat das überleitet. Insane Beatboxing, ja, gibt es jetzt zum Beispiel von Spencer X. Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein. Geil. Mehr dürfen wir nicht zeigen. Ist nicht rechtlich, sondern weil es zu krass ist. Es ist zu krass. Wie Richard Wagner meinte, wenn Tristan und die Solde richtig aufgeführt wird, ist es zu krass. Und Leute würden davon nie wieder sich erholen können. Ja, das ist einfach. Aber was bedeutet das? Sie würden dann einfach durchdrehen und es ist zu zu intensiv. Und das ist genau das Gleiche. Rein rechtlich hätten wir kein Problem, es zu Ende zu zeigen. Das heisst, hat es denn hier schon mal jemand richtig aufgeführt, so dass es am Ende wirklich zu krass war, dass die Leute da rausgetaumelt sind und gesagt haben, das hat mir echt dieses Gehirn verknotet, hat mir diese Napsen verwohlen. Das hat mir gerade den Teppich unterm Hirn weggezogen. Ne, bislang noch nicht, bis dato noch nicht. Also es wurde noch nie richtig aufgewirkt. Das heißt eigentlich, jede Inszenierung ist eigentlich gescheitert. Ja. Bei Tristian Esolde, wenn die am Ende nicht komplett von den Socken, wenn da noch ein Socke übrig ist. Wenn noch ein einziger Zuschauer, eine einzige Zuschauerin in ihren Socken das Konzert beenden kann, dann ist es gescheitert. Es ist einfach durch. Ja, die werden auch, das merkt man auch häufig,
wie die Dirigentin oder Dirigentin werden so in den letzten
Takten ein bisschen nervös. Und dann schielen die immer so runter
und dann hier vorne, Reihe drei,
Reihe drei, Deigen gibt mir ein bisschen
mehr an die Socken, alle haben die Socken an,
Scheiße, Reihe drei,
und dann letzter Takt,
und dann
und dann und dann und dann und dann und dann und dann und dann und dann und dann und dann ein Department Scheisse baut, wenn der genauso umgesetzt wird, wie ich das will, dann kann das Publikum nicht mehr erholen von diesem Film. Und das ist alles normal. Also es ist so selbstbewusst, das wird ja heute niemand mehr sagen, weisst du, was ich meine? Wenn man mein Album hört, danach wird man aus den Socken gehauen. Haben wir das nicht gesagt bei Folge 18, 28? Ja, ja, genau. Haben wir doch gesagt, wenn dieser Podcast vernünftig mit gutem Sound-Equipment, mit einer guten Box, auf einem guten MP3-Player, in einer guten Trambahn. Auf so einer Harman-Kardon-Anlage, die laut wird.
Wenn das richtig perfekt gehört wird, dann könnte man danach eigentlich nie wieder einen Podcast hören. Nee. Weil es einem, wie wenn man, ich mag das manchmal, wenn man was isst, was lecker ist, dass man das dann nochmal so aufstösst. Ach so. So den Tag über. Und man will danach nichts trinken oder so, weil man den Geschmack erhalten will. Ja genau, man will sich das so ein bisschen bewahren. Das ist nochmal so ein Handschlag für einen guten alten Kumpel, den man in der Schule
kennengelernt hat, der dann nochmal irgendwie so auf Facebook irgendwie so rechte Parolen postet, wo das nochmal so hochkommt, wo man nochmal so ein wohliges Gefühl im Magen hat und man einfach war, okay. Das ist Dennis. So sind Dennis, die wir ihn lieben. Gäbe es denn irgendwas, was einen, ich denke jetzt ein Abnehmen, dass man gar nicht was isst, sondern nur eine Tablette runterwirft, die dann im Magen erzeugt, dass wenn man aufstösst, es nach Lasagne schmeckt.
Ah ja, finde ich super.
Also sozusagen der Backburner.
Also ein Anti-Kaugummi meinst du eigentlich so ein bisschen.
Ja, finde ich super. Ich habe auch wieder darüber nachgedacht, das einzige Gemüse, was ich
abgöttisch liebe, Gemüse,
ist Knoblauch.
Liebe ich.
Finde ich absolut fantastisch.
Ist mega gesund. Und selbst
das hat einen riesen Backlash.
Alles, was du,
was man mag,
Genussmittel,
haben alle einen Nachteil. Die meisten sind super ungesund, strömen zwar Zucker, stösst wahnsinnig viel Dopamin und Zucker aus und sowas und dir geht es danach gut.
Du bist ein bisschen wacher, du hast Energie, aber du nimmst halt zu und es ist in rauen Mengen ungesund.
Und das gleiche ist bei so einem Gemüse, was ja eigentlich super harmlos daherkommen sollte, was aber so lecker ist. Und selbst da muss man die Natur sagen, nee, aber dann stinkst du danach eine Woche lang aus deinem Mundloch. Ist halt die Frage, ob es nicht deswegen so gut ist, weil du weisst, ich habe danach... Es schmeckt fantastisch. Es ist eine Sünde, es ist die Sünde, die dann da reingeht. Es schmeckt fantastisch. Meinst du nicht? Und ich würde es mehr essen, wenn es nicht diesen Backlash hätte. Na, das weiss ich nicht. Das weiss ich nicht.
Und dann habe ich aber nachgedacht, was ist etwas, was uneingeschränkt gut tut, aber keinen Nachteil hat für Menschen. Und ich bin, das wird jetzt zotig, aber es ist Masturbation und Sex. Beides hat ausschliesslich Vorteile. Masturbation und Sex, also regelmässige Ejakulation beugen Prostatakrebs vor. Dir geht es besser, du stößt auch Glückshormone aus, du bist entspannter. Es ist eine tolle Zeitbeschäftigung, weil du probierst es da draußen einfach mal aus. Und es hat tatsächlich gar keinen Nachteil. Gar keinen Nachteil. Nee, eigentlich nicht. Du musst halt nur eine Situation finden, du kannst jetzt nicht jederzeit, es ist natürlich so ein Bospriates, aber das ist auch so ein Ding und das ist für mich.
Ich weiß was Lateinisches verstanden, Ubus Priates habe ich verstanden, nicht was Privates.
Ubus Priates, die Sünde, wenn du so die Sünde vertrittst.
Wahnsinn, Florentin, haupt er sich so. Also dieses Gesetz nennt man Ubus Priates.
Und ich hätte es geglaubt.
Ich glaube, eine gewisse Undeutlichkeit in der Aussprache kann auch einfach oft als Intelligenz wahrgenommen werden,
weil Latein ist einfach ein bisschen schlampig ausgesprochen.
Ich habe auch darüber nachgedacht, manchmal finde ich die besten Ideen, die ich jemals hatte,
kreativ, die ich am besten finde oder beste Ideen bewerte, sind oft falsch verstandene Filme zum Beispiel. Also wenn ein Film zu schnell oder zu kompliziert für mich war und ich dachte, ach, ich dachte, die meinen das so. Und dann sagt jemand neben mir, ist ja auch nicht so schlecht. So wie Starship Troopers, da gibt es ja diese Szene, wo es spielt in der Zukunft und dann duschen dann alle zusammen. Und das ist eine berühmte Szene, beide Geschlechter duschen zusammen und es ist überhaupt kein Thema so. Und es wurde so rezipiert als, ah, in der Zukunft ist man da total drüber weg, es gibt keinen Charme, die Geschlechter sind gleichberechtigt und alles. Und der Regisseur hat irgendwann mal gesagt, dass das Ausdruck sein soll einer zukünftigen faschistischen Gesellschaft, in der die Leute überhaupt keine Libido mehr aufbauen, sondern so in ihrem militärischen faschistischen Wahnsinn sind, dass es gar nichts mehr aufbaut und eigentlich eher was Negatives ist. Ach, fast. Und alle so, ah. Nee, wir fanden unsere Idee viel besser und auch cooler. Eigentlich das, was ich habe, eigentlich besser. Ja, ich finde das, was ich falsch verstanden habe und fehlend habe, eigentlich viel, viel cooler. Aber Masturbation ist ein interessantes Thema, das mich umtreibt. Und ich wollte immer schon, weil mich interessiert es total, wie das dann ist, weil das hat ja auch dann viel mit Hormonhaushalt zu tun und sowas. Und ich habe mal einen E-Sport-Psychologen interviewt. Und was mich total interessiert hätte, oder generell an Sportpsychologen, ich weiss nicht, ob man da sowas generell sagen kann, ist, wie ist es denn mit männlichen Sportlern, gibt es da von Psychologen Empfehlungen, also vor dem Spiel schon masturbieren oder gerade nicht oder vielleicht ein paar Tage nicht um irgendwelche, weil Hormone und irgendwie so Testest der Hund. Du denkst auch an Shows von uns. Zum Beispiel, ja, zum Beispiel. Ich meine, das hat ja zum Beispiel mit der körperlichen Leistungsfähigkeit wahrscheinlich was zu tun, zu diesem Hormonhaushalt. Und da hat sich doch hundertprozentig schon mal ein Sportpsychologe mit auseinandergesetzt und gesagt hat, Jungs, lasst mal zwei Tage vorm Spiel. Und das würde mich total interessieren, weil ich glaube, das ist noch unausgeschöpftes Potential. Ja, super. Oder gibt es da auch unter Sportlern so eine, einfach eine Regel so, nee, ins Privatleben gehen wir nicht, aber bestimmt, oder?
Das ist ja auf gar keinen Fall. Die gehen ja auch massiv rein, was Ernährung angeht und Sportler dürfen nicht alles essen, das ist ja auch sozusagen privater Kram.
Ja, ja. Klar können die dann irgendwie Pizza essen gehen, aber wenn die da tausendmal eben bei Albert, Albero, Claudio, ne Mann, ne, halt irgendein Italiener mal, Piazza, ja, na gut, ähm, Francescana oder, oder, ähm, Albero, Venezia. So das Gehirn von Stefan. Was ist das erste technische Name, der uns einfällt?
Alberto.
Das müssen wir noch ein bisschen ... Nee, nee, nee, nee. Da müssen wir noch ... Nee, das können wir so nicht rausgeben. Jungs, keine schlechten Ideen, Brainstorming. Fällt euch noch was anderes ein? Und dann geht einer so an die ... Klauio. Geht einer an die Tafel und streicht so das T durch. Albero. Und das Gehirn ... Nein, mein Problem war, ich gehe gerne zu einem Italiener, der heisst albero, bla bla bla, und den wollte ich jetzt nicht doxen. Damit der nicht überflutet wird von Neidern, die so sein wollen wie Stefan Tietze, wie der Titzmeister. Nein, aber dann sind die dann immer alle da, oder er wird zu voll, oder man weiss, wo ich dann wohne. Das ist Futterneid einfach so. Du willst nicht, dass die Leute dir das Essen wegessen. Nehmen wir meine gute Lasagne wegfressen, meine Kalzone. Die gute Kalzone! Die gute Kalzone! Deswegen habe ich das, Albero heisst nämlich Baum. Und was heisst dann Alberto? Also der Bäumling. Der Bäumling, ja. Okay. Das ist das alte italienische Volk, was halb Italiener, halb Baum ist.
Enz, eigentlich italienische Enz.
Im Grunde, ja. Enzo sagt man ja auch.
Enzos, genau, daher kommt der Name.
Sind langsame, langsam Sprecher, wir können jetzt nicht schon wieder.
Ich wollte jetzt, weißt du, wo ich hingehen wollte?
Ich wollte jetzt einen riesen elaborierten Sketch mit langsam sprechenden Italienern machen.
Wäre lustig gewesen, weil die reden ja gemeinhin ist das Klischee sehr schnell. Da wollte ich nicht hastige, aber dann, wir können nicht schon wieder in diese Herr der Ringe Richtung abschweifen. Was ist denn los mit uns in letzter Zeit? Ich höre gerade diese scheisse Hörbücher. Ach so, du hast diese Verluchten verdammigten Hörbücher. So, ähm, gibt es sportpsychologische Studien zu Masturbation und Spitzensportland? Weil du langsam sprichst, weiss ich deswegen nicht unbedingt mehr. Er stell dir vor, jetzt würde irgend so ein total unbekannter Bundesliga-Verein irgendwie freisingen oder was, würde plötzlich die Bundesliga gewinnen und alle fragen, was ist das Geheimnis und die nur so und würden das gar nicht sagen. Und am Ende kommt es irgendwann raus, weil es einen Whistleblower gibt, der dann das Geheimnis verrät. Die vorhandenen Quellen konzentrieren sich eher auf allgemeine Themen der Sportpsychologie oder die Ausführung von Masturbation auf die Gesundheit und das Wohlbefinden, ohne spezifische Bezugnahme auf Spitzensportler. Hundert Prozent ist es ein gut gehütetes Geheimnis hinter Kabinentüren, dass die Sportpsychologen dann sagen so, hier, äh, hier, Rico, Rico Müller, hier, schau doch Sag mal, dass du hier vorm spitzen spiel noch mal einmal ein elfer dass du noch mal ein elfer verwandelst okay also dass du dir noch mal schön die war nicht warm schiessen oder dass du mal die latte also dass du mal die latte flankst dass du mal eine bananenflanke an die Latte machst, dass du mal den Libero auswechselst.
Ich bin Psychologe, kein Fussballtrainer. Ja, das ist so lustig, wie man erwartet von uns, dass wir in jeder Situation für den Humor irgendwie zurechtfinden, dass wir schon in jede Figur reingehen. Aber wir kommen auch an unsere Grenzen, muss man einfach mal sagen. Gibt es da eine Möglichkeit, meinst du nicht, wenn wir vor der Aufnahme... Wir wissen auch nicht alles, masturbieren, uns gegenseitig einen runterholen. So, okay, aber jetzt ist es mal auf dem Tisch, dass wir einfach vor der Aufnahme fünf oder je nachdem, Also hunderttausend Minuten, also eine Million Stunden. Wie handhabt ihr das da draußen? Hört uns da vielleicht ein, hört uns ein Fussballer? Gibt's ein Fussballer? Es muss uns da ein Fussballer hören, oder? Gibt's eine Spitzenfussballerin? Gibt's irgendeinen Profifussballer? Hört uns irgendwer und sagt mal, gibt's in eurem Verein die Regel? Das würde mich mal sehr interessieren. Aber auch sonst gibt's Jobs, wo das vielleicht Thema ist. Es ist natürlich schon ein krasser Eingriff ins Private und auch eine super intime Frage. Aber ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass das für viele Vereine der Geheimtritt ist. Ich habe kein System, also halt wie es passt, aber ich habe jetzt kein System, wo ich sage, uh, ich muss noch oder so.
Meistens reist man an dem Tag an und dann geht man direkt dahin, dann sehen wir uns direkt, dann verschwindet die Flur in die 15 Minuten am Klo und dann gehen wir auf die Bühne. Also es ist eigentlich gar keine Zeit. So ist das nun mal. Aber ich habe kein System. Mich würde es natürlich interessieren, weil auch ich sehe meinen Körper wie einen Hochleistungsathleten, halt nur in Richtung Podcasting. Aber auch da will ich alles rausholen. Ja, ja, klar. Ich finde das super spannend. Man sagt ja sowas wie, wenn man länger nicht masturbiert, erhöht sich der Testosteronspiegel. Da gibt es so ein paar Studien, aber die sind, also ich weiß nicht, also ich habe es noch nicht handfest gefunden, aber es wird wohl so angeforscht, diese Annahme und dann ist natürlich, Testosteron ist natürlich super gut und wichtig, theoretisch für bessere Leistungsfähigkeit sportlicher Natur. Und man hat auch mal herausgefunden, dass Fussballer, die zu Hause spielen, Heimspiel haben, einen höheren Testosteronwert haben. So Revierverteidigungsmässig. Ach so, okay. Und das schon auch ein bisschen zu einer Leistungssteigerung beitragen kann. Heimspiel ist also nicht nur wegen der Fans ein bisschen ein Heimvorteil. Ich dachte, du gehst in Richtung, weil da dann halt auch die Familien sind und die Frauen wohnen und sie dann bei Heimspielen mehr Sex haben als bei Auswärtsspielen. Gehst von sehr treuen Fußballern noch aus. Für mich sind das absolut treue Socken. Träue Tomaten. Absolut. Oder nicht, gibt's da Gerüchte? Also hast du Gerüchte? Nee, ja, nee, ja. Ah, guck mal, das Gesicht sagt ja. Nein, ja, nein. Das Gesicht sagt ja. Wen hast du gesehen, wen hast du gesehen, wen hast du gesehen bei Obi? Nein, nein. Wen hast du gesehen bei Obi in der Bettenausstellung? Nein, nein. Wen hast du da unter der Decke in der Obi-Bettenausstellung gesehen? Wen hast du gesehen? Wer ist es? Komm, raus damit, raus damit. Die Obi-Bettenausstellung. Hast du jemals einen Fuss vor den anderen durch die Haustür aus? Jetzt leg dich ab, jetzt leg dich ab. Wen hast du in Bällebad gesehen? Wen hast du gesehen? Nein. Wen hast du gesehen? Ja, Rico Müller. Rico Müller, nein, die alten drei Sackets. Jetzt kommen aber die Schlagzeilen, du, jetzt kommen die Schlagzeilen. Ähm, nee, ich habe keine Gerüchte, aber wenn ihr welche habt, richtet die doch mal an uns. Ich wüsste gern mehr, so Sachen, die nicht jeder weiß. Auch privates Gerüchte und so, ja. Ich wüsste gern weniger. Warst du so ein Tratschmaul? Überhaupt nicht. Wurden dir Geheimnisse anvertraut, viele? Also hattest du so... Ich war nie in den Kreisen, wo man für sowas Interesse hatte. Ich kann auch Geheimnisse nicht gut für mich behalten. Ich bin tatsächlich jemand, dem man eher Dinge nicht sagt, weil ich schon sehr viel einfach immer dann erzähle. Gar nicht böse gemeint, aber es ist halt wirklich, ich bin sehr eins zu eins in dem, was ich sage.
Von daher glaube ich, bin ich kein guter Anspruch für, aber ich würde gerne mehr wissen, einfach so, wer mit wem hinterm Rücken und sowas.
Ich glaube, ich merke mir das in der Regel auch nicht so, ich habe das dann nicht so,
ich habe glaube ich auch mal irgendwie zwei Kollegen so nach der Arbeit irgendwie, war noch nachtsachts oder so party und dann bin ich irgendwie nach hause und habe auf dem weg zwei kollegen halt in so einer gassen situation zurückgezogenen knutsch situation gesehen und ich habe die so gesehen und ich habe nicht reagiert und am nächsten tag wusste ich nicht mehr wer das war ich wusste ich dachte mir so war doch was ich wusste wirklich nicht mehr und selbst wenn wenn es eine Betrugssituation wäre, wüsstest du ja auch nicht von den beiden die private Situation. Überhaupt nicht. Wohingegen alle anderen sagen, was? Oh nein. Oh nein, da bräuchte ich jetzt alles zusammen. Die Vanessa mit dem Rubens. Rubens. Mit dem Rubensinger. Nein, kann doch nicht sein. Ich habe ein Knöllchen bekommen. Uff, ich habe verkehrsgesündigt. Hundo Millo, wie viele Millionen waren es? Ganz moderat. Aber jetzt, dann passiert immer was Lustiges. Es kommt nämlich dann Brief nach Hause mit einem lustigen Bildchen. Und sie wurden gemessen von dem Tektronic 9000 Blitzomator und wurden hier auf der Autobahn gemessen. Und dann steht da drunter, geben Sie den Vorfall zu und dann muss man das zugeben und dann kriegt man einen Überweisungsträger und dann muss man das überweisen. Und dann steht aber, wenn man genau liest, steht da drunter, man muss sich nicht strafbar machen. Das weiss ich ja auch aus meinen ganzen Krimis, die ich gucke und meinem ganzen Barbara-Sahle-Richter-Alexander-Holt wissen. Die ganzen knallharten Verkehrspolizeikrimis, die du so gerne anschaust mit den ganzen Geschwindigkeitsübertretungen und Falschparkern, wo ständig irgendwie intensivste Polizeiarbeit dokumentiert wird. High Stakes, Leuten ist der Schweiß zu sich getrieben. Das ist so, manchmal ist es richtig gruselig zu gucken. Das ist so spannend, meine Filme. Die hätten ja fast den Falschparker dann erwischt, aber dann war es der richtige, dann haben wir den observiert. Da musste ich fast aus dem Kino gehen. Ja, die laufen alle auf dem Kino, ja. Und dann ist es ab sechs freigegeben. Das ist so verrückt, ey. Das ist so verrückt. Ich meine, gut, da gab es auch so viele Mordszenen, aber da habe ich wirklich gedacht, ich muss jetzt aus dem Kino. Er hat ja gesagt, das ist sein Fahrrad, wo er das Schloss abgeschnitten hat, aber dann frage ich mich halt, wenn es sein Fahrrad ist, warum hat er dann keinen Schlüssel? Also, sorry, ich will dich jetzt gar nicht emotional dazu. Ich habe dir gesagt, ich möchte mir über den Film nachdenken, ich möchte nicht mehr darüber reden. Okay, es tut mir leid, sorry, weil ich dachte nur, ich habe ja auch ein Fahrrad und ich habe ja einen Schlüssel für mein Schloss. Flontien. Ich will es ja nicht auf ... Ich weiss, dass du glaubst, er ist unschuldig, aber ... Ich finde es furchtbar. Das sind meine Krimis. Und dann steht ja drunter, man muss sich nicht selber ... Nicht anstiften. Man muss sich nicht selber schuldstrafbar machen. Man kann die Aussage verweigern. Dann habe ich ein Kreuz, ich verweigere die Aussage, schick es zurück, weil ich dachte, jetzt bin ich mal gespannt. Jetzt habe ich ja die Macht des Gesetzes hinter mir, jetzt beweist mir mal das Gegenteil. Vor allem, ich dachte mir, warum müssen Sie diese Frage haben, die man Foto von mir und diesen Blitzomator, der spuckt das Ergebnis raus. Das heißt, Sie müssen jetzt nochmal zu dem Blitzomator und müssen da nochmal eine Aussage. Wir haben ja alle Beweise. So und dann kam nochmal ein Brief, so, wir konnten es nicht zuordnen, genau, geben Sie den Verstoss zu, ja oder nein. Ich musste nur angeben, das musste ich machen, wer der Fahrer ist, habe ich meinen Namen eingegeben. und dann kam, da habe ich nochmal, als ich als Fahrer den Brief bekommen und dann stand da nur noch, geben Sie den Vorfall zu, ja oder nein. Sie müssen sich aber nicht selber strafbar machen. Da habe ich wieder angeklickt, ich möchte die Aussage verweigern. Und ich fand das so, was passiert jetzt, habe ich einen Loophole gefunden, ist das nicht alles genial? Du bist jetzt observiert, jetzt stehen so Kommissare in Autos vor deiner Tür, be beobacht nicht weil das ist der heisseste fall gerade in köln und dann kam der brief bitte überweisen die 25 euro aber das fand ich so ich finde das ganz spannend ja du hast ganz kurz rebelliert gegen system kurz gefühlt wie ein outlaw der dagegen ist gegen den grossen staen Staatsapparat, aber am Ende, nee, jetzt mach's doch.
Bitte bezahl doch einfach.
Das ist genauso wie wir Eltern sagen, so, wenn du jetzt nicht die Hausaufgaben machst, dann aber.
Ja, was dann?
Ja, drei, drei, zwei, drei, drei, drei, drei, drei, drei, drei, drei, drei, drei, die Zahl drei, zwei, eins sieben Achtel, eins fünf Siebtel. Boah, das ist so. Und am Ende, ja, mach's einfach, ich zähle bis drei. Pass auf, ich hab eine Idee. Jeder Podcast-Ufo-Zuhörer spendet ein Euro von diesen. Für deine, für deine. Und dann kann ich so einen Topf aufbauen, dann habe ich so einen Budgettopf, und dann kann ich davon die Strafen bezahlen. Ja. Oder andersrum gedacht, jeder Podcast-Ufo-Hörer, jede Podcast-Ufo-Hörerin, die einen Strafzettel kriegt mit so einem Bild, schickt uns das Bild, und wenn sie nachweisen können, dass sie in dem Moment das Podcast-Ufo gehört haben, zahlen wir die Strafe. Aber da musst du das Handy in den Blitz erhalten, was zwei Punkte und eine Freiheitsstrafe mitzutzt. Und das Handy mit dem Cover muss, also ihr sollt das nicht absichtlich deswegen machen. Aber nur, falls ihr, sagen wir mal, ihr habt das Kopfhörer in den Ohren, das sieht man auf dem Foto. Und ihr habt so ein seliges Lächeln auf den Lippen. So ein Mensch, der Tietze, was der wieder treibt. So was, wenn ihr das nachweisen könnt, dann zahlen wir für euch die Strafe. Ah, geil! Das finde ich gut. Ich wünsche, das wäre am Anfang gekommen. Ja, dann übernehmen wir für euch die Strafe. Das finde ich super. Oder dann könnt ihr reinschreiben bei Fahrer Stefan Tietze und dann geht das alles an Stefan Tietze und dann zahlt er das Ganze. Ja, schickt uns offene Angelegenheiten, also schickt uns dann mal bitte die Fotos. Und wenn ihr nachweisen könnt, dass ihr währenddessen Podcast-Ufo gehört habt, zahlen, egal was es ist. Oder ich würde sogar sagen, die lustigste Situation zahlen wir. Die lustigste Situation unter 75 Euro, unter 50 Euro. Unter 30 Euro. Also das lustigste Foto unter 30 Euro zahlen wir euch. Genau, wenn es weniger als 20 Euro kostet und ihr uns das Bild schickt, übernehmen wir das. Wenn ihr in der Situation Podcast-Hufe gehört habt. Ja, das... Ja, okay. Bis 15 Euro.
Bis 15 Euro.
Das kostet nicht, muss viel mehr kosten. Weil du musst ja das, das ist ja, ich glaube, es ist sogar verboten, mit Ohrhörern zu Auto zu fahren. Ja, okay. Bin mir nicht sicher. Bin mir nicht sicher. Nage mich nicht darauf fest, weil man kann ja auch sehr laut Radio hören, ich verstehe den Unterschied nicht. Aber ich glaube, es ist, beim Fahrradfahren ... Ja, gut, du hörst halt dann so Außengeräusche wahrscheinlich weniger. Ich musste auch letztens lange Autofahren und es war ein kompletter Kampf, weil ich habe ja, also du hast ja so moderne Autos, Carsharing-mäßig, hast du ja manchmal auch ein modernes Auto, also manchmal auch irgendwie so ein Vieracker-Kutsche oder so, manchmal dann irgendwie so ein alten Ford oder so, Ford Modell Y und manchmal hast du aber auch ein relativ modernes Raumschiff.
Ja, genau.
Das ist ein richtiger Krach.
Cybertruck.
Und die haben dann auch so eine eingebaute Spurassistenzhilfe, dass wenn du die Spur verlässt, lenken die dich automatisch wieder zurück.
Ja.
Was super ist, cool, aber wenn du halt über hunderte Kilometer Baustellen fährst, wo halt ständig diese Linien verschoben sind, musst du halt ständig dagegen arbeiten, weil du ja ständig so auf die Linien fährst, was ich nicht kann, kann ich nicht, und das heisst, stundenlang bin ich gefahren, immer im Kampf gegen das Auto, das sagt, aber ich will dir doch helfen, Meister, ich will dir helfen, ich bin doch dein Freund, und er so, nein, nein, nein, die ganze Zeit. Gegen deinen Tod ankämpfst, aber das habe ich auch nicht verstanden. Die ganze Zeit, ey! Gerade bei, erst mal sind die nicht eigentlich immer cool lesbar, wahrscheinlich für so einen Computer, diese Fahrbahnmarkierungen. Manchmal sind die halt auch schon uralt und so ausgeblichen. Und dann bei Baustellen sind dann gelbe drüber. Genau. Ich glaube, der erkennt aber, die sind gelb, die sind wichtiger, die überschreiben weiß.
Der hat er bei mir nicht erkannt. Das ist ja unfassbar.
Ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, stundenlang und ich so, ah, die ganze Zeit dagegen. Es ist wirklich furchtbar. Es war wirklich so ein Kampf, so wie wenn du an so einer Klippe stehst und jemand will dich nach hinten ziehen, aber du sagst, ich will Bungee Jumping, ich bin sicher und jemand immer so, nein, nein, nein und du musst die ganze Zeit ankämpfen. Aber es war absolut furchtbar.
Genau, aber es ist wirklich so wie so, nein, nein, nein und du musst die ganze Zeit ankämpfen.
Aber es war absolut furchtbar.
Genau, aber es ist wirklich wie so eine gaussische Kurve, wie cool, also du kannst diesen Punkt überschreiten, an dem es nicht mehr cool ist, die technischen Hilfsleistungen. Ja, genau. Es ist wirklich so, also je krasser. Die wollen dir helfen, so ich check schon, was du willst, aber nein, danke, gerade nicht. Weil ich bin auch mal so ein Carsharing-Auto gefahren, was dann auch lächerlich cool war.
Es hatte nämlich ein Tempomat drin und einen Abstandshalter zum Vordings, Vordermann und man muss dann ja gar nicht mehr auf dem Gaspedal sein, sondern der checkt dann, erhält einfach den Abstand hinter deinem Auto, was vor dir fährt. Völlig entspannt kann man dann fahren und dann gibt es auch auch zum Beispiel einen Limiter. Der Limiter sagt, egal wie viel Gas du gibst, ähm, du kannst maximal einstellend, maximal 50 fahren bei so einer Baustelle. Stellst du ein, maximal 50. Und egal wie viel Gas du gibst, der fährt maximal 50 und es kann dir nichts passieren, dass du zu schnell fährst und geblitzt fährst. Ähm, oder generell sollte man auch nicht zu schnell fahren. So. Und dann gibt es aber so ein, hat das Auto auch noch gehabt, so ein Kickdown-Ding. Wenn man das Gaspedal ganz runterdrückt, im normalen Fahrsituation, gibt es nochmal extra Gas. Es gab so ein, wie bei Need for Speed dieses Nitro-Ding. Ja, so ein Boost. Ja, ja. So ein Pilz quasi. Man kann einmal das Gas wieder runterdrücken und dann gibt es diesen Pilzeffekt, wenn du nochmal doller drunter drückst, macht so einen kleinen Klackgeräusch und dann gibt es richtig Gas. Und ich natürlich mega stolz, dass dieser Limiter, dass ich den eingestellt habe und fahre dann so rum und drücke dann so aufs Gasbäder und dachte mir, oh cool, guck mal, es passiert ja gar nichts. Und dann habe ich diesen Kick betätigt und der Wagen überschreibt, das Kickdown überschreibt den Limiter. Also Leute, also wenn das nicht Relatable Comedy ist, weiß ich auch nicht, wie wir unseren Riesen... Wie Lambo Steffen, der irgendwie in der Nähe von Duisburg unterwegs ist und düst. Wir nehmen unseren Car2to-go, Drive-now, Riesen-Kutschen, mit denen wir die Innenstädte unsicher machen. Aber das war wirklich, wo ich dachte, jetzt reicht's. Aber ich glaube, die Technik ist so weit fortgeschritten, dass sie uns helfen will. Aber ob wir die Hilfe wollen oder nicht, das sind so die Backseater. Ich weiss noch mal, da haben wir irgendwas gedreht und sind so im Auto gefahren und wir hatten so Handkameras, die man so gehalten hat und die hatten die Einstellung, dass die immer auf dein Gesicht sich ausrichten. Egal wo die die hinhälste, er kennt dein Gesicht und zeigt, du bist immer im Mittelgrund. Ja, genau. Du bist immer in der Mitte, so die beobachtet dich immer so. An sich total geil, wenn du Vlogger bist oder Skifahr-Vlogger oder halt irgendwie Achterbahn-Vlogger oder halt irgendwie so dann keine Ahnung, Bergsteigvlogger bist oder so oder du bist halt dann irgendwie in so einem Supermarktvlogger und hast in einer Hand. Aber nicht geil, wenn du so. Und dann hieß es so, ja, film mal nach draussen, film mal so während dem Autofahren so nach draussen, wie der so die Umgebung an euch vorbeizieht. Und ich, okay, gut, aber ich konnte die Kamera schlicht nicht drehen, weil es nicht ging. Und dann habe ich diesen Kamerakopf, und das war so ein Kugelkopf, habe ich den gepackt und habe ihn gegen seinen Willen gedreht nach außen. Und alles, was er wollte, war wieder zurück. Und er hat sich gewehrt und gekämpft, weil er wollte zurück zu dem Gesicht und nicht so, nein, nein, du willst mich nach draußen, ich bin dein Meister, ich bin und ich drück ihn so nach draußen und das waren die unbrauchbarsten Aufnahmen aller Zeiten. Ich will den Kalender, Florentin gegen technische Hilfsmittel. Weil auch die Aufnahmen waren so, du hast gemerkt, die Kamera will das nicht filmen und das fühlt sich ganz schlecht an. Und das ist so, als würde sie da gar nicht hin, nein, nein, zeig mir das nicht. Und ich wollte sich immer so wegdrehen und es war so ein Schwachsinn, aber da dachte ich mir auch, wo sind wir jetzt gelandet einfach, dass die Technik zu weit geht.
Ist es nicht wie Will Smith bei I'm Legend, der dann sagt, wenn seine Tochter noch irgendwie in diesen Helikopter steigt und sagt, guck mich an, guck einfach nur mich an, guck einfach nur mich an, guck nicht raus, guck nicht nach rechts und links.
So ist diese Kamera und die will nur zu dir gucken, die will nicht diese unheilvolle Welt da draußen beobachten.
Aber das will ich jetzt sehen. Eine Compilation aus Florentin-Videos, wie du gegen die Technik kämpfst, sehr, sehr wortwörtlich. Im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes. So Schiebetüren, Drehtüren sind auch immer ein Riesenproblem, wenn man da nochmal raus will. Boah, bei Ikea kriegen es die Leute immer nicht hin. Da werden wirklich so 50 Leute drängen sich in diese Tür rein und dann bleiben die stehen, weil Leute nicht schnallen, dass man nicht an diese Tür gehen soll. Menschen sind im Kollektiv wahnsinnig dumm manchmal. So dumm. Unglaublich dumm. Ehre dumm. Dass es uns doch gibt, ne, also ich weiss nicht, vielleicht gibt es uns bald nicht mehr, aber aktuell, wir sind noch da. Aber eines Tages hängen wir alle in einer, weil einfach die gesamte Menschheit mal durch eine Drehtür will. Ist das nicht eine Gameshow? Ab wie vielen Leuten ist man dumm? So, du hast so, keine Ahnung, du hast so einen Kandidaten und dann hast du ein Quiz, da hast du irgendwie so einen schlauen Typen. Und dann machst du das Quiz und dann kriegt der 80 Punkte von 100. Und dann kriegt er das nächste Quiz, aber jemand anders sitzt jetzt dabei. Und die müssen zu zweit sich auf die Lösung einigen. Besser, glaube ich. So, und jetzt sind die ja... Erstmal besser. Erstmal besser, glaube ich auch. Drei noch besser. Kriegen sie jetzt 90 von 100, zu dritt 95 von 100. Ich glaube, in dieser Situation werden die immer besser. Ja, meinst du? In dieser Situation werden die immer, immer besser. Und dann, das ist ja die Frage. Und dann ist die Frage, so acht Kandidaten, neun, zehn, irgendwann muss ja so eine Massendummheit einsetzen. Ist ja die Frage, wenn man es macht, ob die dann wählen, die richtige Antwort wählen oder ob einer dann der Anführer ist oder so. Und dann kannst du ja verschiedene Staatsformen auch durchprobieren. Finde ich super. Was istarchie, wo einfach einer dann nur so sich die Vorschläge geben lässt, aber am Ende immer einer entscheidet oder was anderes, wo gewählt wird. Ja, genau. Oder die müssen erst jemanden wählen, der dann der König ist, der kann aber auch wieder Misstrauensvotum. Du hast verschiedene politische Systeme, die in einer Quizshow gegeneinander antreten. Und du siehst, da kannst du ja jede Staatsform so übereinander legen. Und du merkst, die Monarchie ist am Anfang super stark, aber wird man ganz viel mehr Leuten schwächer. Die Demokratie wird vielleicht auch immer schwächer, je weniger Leute es sind. Dafür ist ein anderer, der Kommunismus ist super stark, wenn es viele sind. Schatz, ich muss sagen, ich habe keinen Bock mehr, mit dem, diese Staatsform zu, also ich meine, es ist eine weirre Gameshow. Schatz, die Anarchisten, die Anarchisten, es sind ja schon 120 pro Person. Es ist die langweiligste Gameshow der Welt.
Nein, Schatz, du verstehst es nicht.
Es sind fünfhundertsechzig Leute auf der Bühne aktuell.
Wir haben Anarchisten, Monarchisten.
Ist erst mal auf, du musst dich jetzt...
Ja, ich habe so viele Snacks.
Das ist der schönste Abend meines Lebens.
Deshalb wir zusammen endlich mal die Staatsform, Quizshow. Auf RTL läuft Pirates of the Caribbean, okay? Ach Quatsch, nein Piraten, das ist doch völlig aus der Zeit gefallen. Das ist doch dieses Kapitänsgefüge. Schatz, Kau! Das ist doch keine vernünftige Staatsform. Du verschluckst dich gleich. Du kannst doch als Kapitän. Warum ist Staatsform so toll? Du kannst doch als Kapitän.
Was ist für ein Name für eine Show? Staatsform. Staatsform Quiz Ab wann sind Menschen dumm. Ab wann sind Menschen dumm. Die grosse Ab wann sind Menschen dumm. Welche Staatsform ist die beste? Untertitel Ab wann sind Menschen dumm. Es sind zwei Konzepte, die konkurrieren. Und am Ende, dann können die auch. Und du konkurrierst auch mit der ... Aber, Schatz, am Ende können wir abstimmen, welcher Aspekt der Sendung uns besser gefallen hat.
Der Staatsformteil oder der Abwann werden Menschen dummteil.
Und dann kann man nochmal abstimmen.
Und deswegen müssen wir es bis Ende angucken.
Warum hast du jetzt, wenn du fertig bist mit deinem Vortrag, aufzuessen?
Ich habe keine Fritt mehr.
Es ist halt lächerlich.
Fritt. Keine Pommes Fritt?
Nee, Fritt. Die lustigen Kaubonbons. Ach, die hast du die ganze Zeit gegessen. Diese Folge wird präsentiert von Fritt. Fritt. Ja, wir haben uns das mit der Werbeintegration ein bisschen anders vorgestellt, als dass jemand das unendlich in sich reinstopft. Ich möchte eigentlich gerne mal so einen Wien-Reiseführer haben, nur für Brettspiele, wo drinsteht, wie man statistisch und mathematisch korrekt Brettspiele spielt. Und dann gehst du auf M, Monopoly. Und dann lese ich mir vor so Monopoly-Abend durch, welche Felder sind die statistisch meistbesuchtesten, wo müsste man am ehesten kaufen? Ist die beste Strategie, immer sofort zu investieren oder gibt es Felder, wo man statistisch häufiger drauf landet? Weil es gibt ja zum Beispiel dieses Gefängnis, da ist man ja relativ häufig, kommt man dann dahin. Von da würfelt man wahrscheinlich eins bis sechs. Das heisst, die Felder davor, dahinter sind wahrscheinlich häufiger besucht. Keine Ahnung, bei den ersten Ideen jetzt. So ein Cheatbuch, so ein Lösungsbuch, Brettspiel-Lösungsbuch. Sie müssen nie wieder Spass haben, nutzen ja einfach das Lösungsbuch. Wollen Sie immer der Beste sein und unsympathisches Arschloch in dem Freundeskreis? Wollen Sie Recht haben. Ja, super, also ideale Form, um aus so einem gesellschaftlichen, sozialen Anlass einfach jede Form von Spass und Gesellschaftlichkeit rauszunehmen. Es ist ja immer noch gewichtet, ist ja immer noch noch ein gewichtetes Glücksspiel. Nur ich habe mehr... Du willst nur eine höhere Chance haben, zu gewinnen. Genau. Ich glaube, wenn die anderen... Man hat ja eher eine gute Runde Monopoly, weißt du? Die habe ich halt dann immer. Ich weiss noch. Ich hatte mal eine richtig gute Runde Monopoly. Ich habe wirklich komplett... 78. Ich habe die Orangen wirklich komplett bekommen. Schon direkt am Anfang. Ist das die hinteren oder die vorderen? Nee, die sind mittig. Also das ist ja so, weil die konnte ich mir gerade noch so leisten, weil das Problem ist, die richtig teuren kannst du ja am Anfang gar nicht alle leisten. Nee. Die Orangen haben so den perfekten ... Nee, genau, du sagst es, du sprichst es wirklich aus. Die Orangen haben so den perfekten Sweetspot zwischen kann man sich schon früh leisten, aber bring genug Ertrag. So, und wenn du die von Anfang an hast, und jede Runde, jede Runde, und ich sag dir, Tante Margret, jedes Mal orange, jedes Mal orange, jedes Mal drauf, jedes Mal cash, cash, cash, cash, cash. Die hat sie da umgebracht, ne? Cash, äh genau, ja, das war ihr letzter Abend mit uns, und ich hab die so fertig gemacht, ey, ich hab die so ausgenommen wie ne ganz, ich hab die so fucking ausgenommen. Du hast immer geschrien, du bist, du kannst nichts, du bist ein Loser. Du kannst nichts, ja, ja, ja. Gib mir dein Geld, gib mir dein Ge-e-e-e-eld, hab ich immer gesagt. Genau. Und dann hab ich die blauen alle gekauft, Schlosserle hab ich alle gekauft. Margaret steht wohl nicht mehr für Money. Hm, SM? Hm? Ja. Die war sehr traurig dann auch. Und danach hat sie es, wie gesagt, die Nacht hat sie nicht, aber ... Nee, aber die drunter war richtig geil. Ja, das war richtig geil. Also da habe ich so geil gespielt, genau wie es im Katalog steht. Genau wie es in der Lösung steht, habe ich gespielt und ich habe die alle abgezogen. Richtig gut. Ich muss es deutlich so lachen. Eine minastehende Person hat Geburtstag und dann haben wir so reingefeiert und dann haben wir in die familiengruppe geguckt hat diese person ob die wer gratuliert hat aus der familiengruppe schon also so bei whatsapp so so nachts genau so um null uhr und um 23 uhr fünfzig hat 52 oder so schreibt jemand in die familiengrupp, dass ein Haustier gestorben ist. Aber jetzt nicht so ein trauriges Haustier, so wie ein Hund oder so, sondern jetzt nicht so spezifisch werden. Ja, gerade Vogel. Ja, so etwas ist ein bisschen egal, so ehrlich gesagt. Okay. Genau. Aber war es ein beliebtes Haustier in der Familie oder eher? Schon, aber es gibt auch mehrere davon, aber es hat nicht gepackt. Und ich fand das tatsächlich sehr lustig, weil und dann hat niemand anderes mehr gratuliert, was ich ja verstehe. Ja, ja, ja. Also darauf müssen ja dann alle erstmal so eine Mitleidsbekundung schreiben, aber du kannst ja nicht schreiben, oh nein, es tut mir so leid für euch, seid stark, alles Gute und alles, alles Liebe zum Geburtstag, Person. Ja, ja. Es ist schwer, das hinzukriegen, die Balance. Und dann war halt die Person, die keine Geburtstagsglückwünsche bekommen hat, relativ enttäuscht, weil niemand aus der Familie geschrieben hat.
Aber ich habe gesagt, nee, aber es geht nicht. Was soll man denn darauf schlagen? Ich habe mich immer kaputt gelacht.
Es ist schwierig, es gibt viele Grusskarten auch für Sorry für deinen Verlust, alles Gute, aber es gibt keine Grusskarten, die sozusagen so zweifarbig sind, so schwarz links und dann so rot rechts, wo du sagst, tut mir leid für deinen Verlust, aber alles Gute zum 28. So, das ist schwer zu kombinieren, aber finde ich super. So lustiges Timing. Es gibt so ein paar Momente, die einfach andere überschatten. Und aber auch einfach, es gibt auch gewisses Timing, an das man sich einfach halten muss. Ist ein schlechtes Timing. Aber hat die Person dann zumindest Beileid bekundet und so, ja, wir sind jetzt alle auf der Party und alle auf meiner Geburtstagsparty schicken mir Beileid. Und Geburtstag gross in Caps geschrieben. Mit diesen Knalltüten links und rechts Emojis, aber ist schwierig. Ja, man kann es nicht machen, aber das fand ich sehr lustig. Aber nach uns gratulieren in der Woche. Ah, jetzt ist gestorben. Doch, macht man. Nee, aber wenn um 23.50, äh, um 23.56, 58 noch alle antworten, oh nein, Fred ist tot, so, dann sind ja alle wach weisst du und dann ist ja
dieses gespräch man ist ja sozusagen jetzt online zusammengekommen virtuell und dann kann man ja auch reinziehen schuhkartongrossen grabstein herum und sagt ach mensch ach ja tatsächlich Das war auch echt lustig.
Bobby, du warst so eine gute Ratte-Vogel.
Aber jetzt Happy Birthday to you, Happy Birthday to you, Happy Birthday! War ein bisschen viel. War ein bisschen viel.
Ich finde diese Vorstellung so lustig, dass eine Mutter am Bett ihres Kindes sitzt. Und meine Mama hat mir auch immer vorgesungen, hat mir immer Gute-Nacht-Lieder gesungen, aber so sehr bedächtig und leise. Und sie ist auch keine Sängerin. Aber die Vorstellung, dass jemand viel zu ernst ist, wie diese inbrünstigen Happy Birthday- dann so Morgen früh, so Gott will, wirst du wieder gewählt. Das Kind ist hellwach. Morgen früh, so Gott, Mama, Mama, Jesus. Ich hätte in der Oper singen können, dann habe ich dich bekommen. Nur weil du gerade Gesangsunterricht hast. Gott, ey. Ich habe so tief geschlafen und dann sitzt du hier am Bett und du singst. Schlaf, Kindlein, schlaf. Ja, ich bin jetzt hellwach. So komplette Choreografie, so eine Musical-Mom. Komplett mit Drehung und Tanz und alles komplett performend. Guten Abend, guten Abend, wenn ein Engel gewacht, Stern und Himmel bedeckt, leg dich wie ... Ich kann nicht immer bei, sorry, bei der Probe ging's noch. Sorry, Schatz. Wir haben das geprübt. Sorry, Schatz, bei der Probe war's ... Wir haben das geprobt. Sorry, Schatz, bei der Probe war's noch ... So lass ich dich nicht vor's Publikum kommen, Eluisa. Dein Vater hat nicht trainiert, dein Vater hat nicht geübt, wir haben den Text nicht geübt. Wir hätten eigentlich ... Wir hätten die Performance absagen sollen. Wir hätten die Performance absagen sollen, jetzt stehen wir hier und ... Es tut mir leid und ... Steht ihr hier bei mir im Zimmer? Und dann ist das die Leistung, die ihr abruft? Wir hätten die Performance absagen sollen. Wir hätten die Performance absagen sollen, jetzt stehen wir hier und es tut mir leid und ...
Steht ihr hier bei mir im Zimmer? Und dann ist das die Leistung, die ihr abruft? Wir hätten, Schatz, es tut mir leid, wir hätten ... Ich weiss, du hast 60 Euro gezahlt fürs Ticket und ... Ich habe mein ganzes Taschengeld bezahlen müssen. Müssen. Für Mamas Kleid. Für Mamas Riesenkleid. Wir haben nicht Dilbert,id. Wir haben nicht die Lippert, wir haben nicht die Lippert. Wir wollten eigentlich gestern noch üben, Probe machen, aber dein Vater war dann doch nicht da und dann haben wir gesagt, machen wir heute morgen noch, aber dann weisst du ja die Sturmflut. Text vergessen, das Hohe Fisten nicht getroffen, die Tanzeinlage nicht genailed. Nimm mir leid, Schatz. Morgen Abend will ich es sehen. Und den dritten Akt auch. Wieder in der Loge? Gut, okay. Und dann in Akt eins. Ja, das Kind ist total begeistert. Schläf sofort ein. So spannend wie, gute Nachtgeschichten müssen spannend sein irgendwie, müssen ja einen Hook haben, einen Spannungsbogen, Figuren müssen von A nach B, Hindernisse stehen im Weg, aber es darf auch nicht zu aufkratzend sein. Nee. Es muss eine gute Mischung sein. Ja, aber es muss eigentlich wie so ein Horrorfilm so eine Spannung aufbauen und dann am Ende, und es war alles nur lila Rauch und Nele, es war gar kein Vampir, sondern nur der Robert, der hat seine Zähne verloren, alle Zähne verloren, bis auf zwei. Und es sah so aus, als ob, und deswegen, gut nach. Ach so. Und auch nicht zu kurz sein, weil dann ist die vorbei und man denkt, ich bin doch komplett wach. Also meine Augen sind noch genauso gross wie immer. Sehe ich müde aus? Sehe ich für dich müde aus? Habe ich gegänt? Habe ich einmal gegänt? Weil du hast aufgehört, ihr habt aufgehört zu lesen. Aber wie ist es, wenn du eine Geschichte vorliest und das Kind gähnt? Ist es ein... Boah, Freude. Man will ja auch wieder vor den Fernseher, um Staatsforum zu gucken.
Schatz, die Werbeunterbreitung von Staatsforum ist fast verlieblich.
Ja, ich lese doch gerade der Luisa vor.
Und dann ist die Frage, das ist so wie wenn sein eigener Song in der Playlist Einschlafen aufgenommen wird.
Ist es ein Kompliment oder nicht? Und so wenn du vorliest, Gann, ist es dann so,
ja, schreib dir nur eine bessere Geschichte, Luisa, schreib dir eine bessere Geschichte als Tolkien. Erstmal vielen Dank, dass du mir Tolkien zum Einschlafen vorliest. Ist vielleicht nicht für Kinder perfekt geeignet und gerade die Stelle mit dem köpfenden Org fand ich, ja, verstörend. Ich habe es gemerkt. Verstörend, drüber. Und mein Gen soll jetzt nicht ausdrucken, wie ich jetzt Langeweile
sein, die ich zum Ausdruck bringen wollte, sondern ist einfach, war einfach müde.
Aha. Ich bin noch ein bisschen müde jetzt.
Okay. Naja, es ist halt auch schon zwei Uhr nachts.
Und wie ich zu Steinmonster gesprochen habe, na, ist ein langes Buch.
Na ja, Kinder sind 18 Uhr im Bett.
Wir müssen halt auch irgendwann durchkommen, ist ein langes Buch. Wir haben noch 60 Seiten vor uns. 16.30 Uhr gehen die ins Bett. Kinder schlafen so lang. Tun die das? Ne, das habe ich jetzt natürlich humoristisch übertrieben, aber die gehen schon sehr früh ins Bett, so 19anzig Uhr. Das ist so lustig. Und schlafen nicht.
Ich glaube, das Gemeine ist, dass du als Kind noch weisst, dass die Eltern noch wach sind.
Nee, aber ...
Dass die noch wach sind. Das ist das Gemeine.
Die Brüder! Die machen Rabatz.
Ich glaube, man sollte dem Kind von Anfang an vorlügen und sagen, wir gehen jetzt alle ins Bett.
Ah.
Gute Nacht, wir gehen jetzt alle ins Bett.
Und dann geht das Kind nachts aufs Klon und hört das Lachen.
Die schauen noch Staatsformen!
Aber wie viele Menschen sind die Menschen dumm auf RTL?
Auf RTL Recht.
Der Fun-Sender.
Ja.
RTL Nerd.
Ach übrigens, vielen, vielen Dank für den tollen Tipp von Only Connect.
Gerne.
Just Connect.
Connect Four. Connect all four. Rössische Quizshow, sehr, sehr schwer auf tollen Tipp von Only Connect. Gerne. Just Connect, Connect Four, Connect All Four.
Riesische Quizshow, sehr, sehr schwer auf YouTube zu sehen, Only Connect, extrem schwer, man fühlt sich extrem dumm, aber wenn man mal eine Antwort weiss oder zufällig gegoogelt hat, dann fühlt man sich sehr stolz. Aber vielen, vielen Dank, Florentin, ich glaube, du hast nicht nur mich glücklich gemacht, sondern auch viele aus der Community. Ich habe es gelesen, ja, freut mich sehr im Reddit, das Podcast-U UFO, da haben viele sich bedankt und viele, auch alte Enthusiasten sich gemeldet zum Thema Only Connect. Was für eine tolle Show. Also ich bin da wirklich verhängen geblieben, tagelang, immer noch, weil es so eine wholesome, alle haben sich gern, es ist eine tolle Stimmung, die Moderatorin ist ja unfassbar clever, lustig und cool. Die ist perfekt, ja. Und da fragt man sich auch, wer soll das in Deutschland überhaupt moderieren? Kann niemand moderieren und ich mag auch, wie no bullshit das auch geschnitten ist. So schnell. Es gibt kein und was macht ihr so und nein hin und dann wirklich auch so das eine Team war dran und dann direkt umschnitt und das andere Team steht schon da an der Connecting Wall und es ist schon da und es geht direkt weiter. Keine einzige Sekunde verschwendet. Es wird nicht verschwendet, es ist wirklich so reduziert zum Maximum, würde man ja sagen. Also es ist wirklich, es gibt nur, wenn man rein zappt, wird eine Frage gestellt oder beantwortet. Es gibt nicht dieses Zwischengeplänkel und Smalltalk-Shit und es sind auch keine Promi-Gäste, die irgendwelche Sachen zu bewerben haben oder sowas, sondern es ist einfach nur coole Leute, die da sind, dem alle coole Geschichten zu erzählen und wenn die mal reden, dann auch coole Sachen. Ja, und man muss dazu sagen, es ist eines der schwersten Quizzes der Welt und die Leute sind sehr, sehr schlau, aber wenn die gewinnen, die zeigen keine Emotionen. Nee. Null. Nichts. Sie sitzen da und es gibt auch kein Ja, freut euch und so, sondern einfach nur so, das war die Sendung, tschüss, bis zum nächsten Mal. Es gibt eine Sendung, wo im Finale jemand gewonnen hat und dann applaudieren die Verlierer. Und das war für mich so ein merkwürdiger Moment, weil noch nie davor irgendwie Emotionen oder irgendwas gezeigt wurde. Gehört da nicht hin. Und es ist einfach so, man sitzt da und dann so, ja, ihr habt gewonnen, ja, bis nächstes Mal und tschüss. Ja. Grossartig. Einmal die zweiköpfige Schlange und die Hieroglyphen auch. Die Hieroglyphen sind das Beste. The Eye of Horrors. Man muss immer so Fragen auswählen und die sind nicht einfach nummeriert, sondern mit so Hieroglyphen oder griechischen Buchstaben und das ist einfach grossartig. Das ist absolut grossartig, also können wir nur empfehlen, das ist so nerdy und cool. Und man denkt sich schon, meine Herren, bin ich dumm. Also was machen die denn, dass sie so viel wissen? Also ich glaube, es gibt natürlich auch diese Pub-Quiz-Kultur und so in England, wo natürlich viele dann wahrscheinlich auch explizit dafür trainieren oder so, oder einfach schlau sind oder das einfach schon seit Jahrzehnten machen. Ja, dieses Trivia-Wissen. Aber man denkt sich wirklich... Es ist schon eine andere Form. Es ist auch nicht unbedingt, ich weiss nicht, Intellekt oder Cleverness oder so. Es ist einfach nur eine wahnsinnige Trivia-Wissen-Belesenheit. Ja, und so schnell. Ich drücke immer Pause, drücke immer Pause. Und denkst du nach? Ich drücke immer Pause und denke nach, weil es so schnell nicht geht. Und letztens war sogar eine Monopoly-Frage dabei. Und da hiesst es dann so, ja, die Beträge irgendwie 650 Pfund, 890 Pfund irgendwie irgendwie. Und dann muss man dann so erraten, was als viertes dann kommen würde. Und jemand sagt dann wirklich die Zahl und er sagt, ah, das sind die addierten Kosten, wenn man sich die jeweiligen Farben kauft bei Monopoly. Das kann doch nicht wahr sein. Ja, das ist Trivia. Also nicht nur auswendig, überhaupt irgendeine Zahl aus Monopoly zu kennen. Ich kenne keine einzige Zahl, null. Nein. Und ausser vielleicht, sie ziehen über Los und ziehen 400 ein, glaube ich. 400? Ich weiss es nicht. 4000? Wir wissen es nicht. 4000? Wir wissen es beide nicht. Und der wusste halt von allem die Zahlen und konnte die addieren. Unfassbar. Unfassbar. Das ist irre. Unglaublich. Ja, also vielen Dank für den Tipp. Was weiss ich stattdessen? Ja. Wie viele Fragen hast du jemals richtig beantwortet? Ich glaub zwei oder so, das ist wirklich nicht so viel. Also pro Sendung, das war wirklich ... Pro Sendung. Und ich hab einfach null Ahnung von den Musikfragen, keine Ahnung? Ja, das war die einzige, die ich bis dato mal relativ schnell richtig hatte, war eine Musikfrage. Oh, nee, das ist nicht schlecht, da ist Respekt. Genau, die Idee ist ja, entweder etwas zu finden, was vier Facts oder was auch immer verbindet, oder das letzte herauszufinden. Dann muss man sozusagen eine Reihe erkennen. Und da war, der erste Song, der kam, war Mission Impossible Theme, der zweite Song, der kam, war Saturday Night Fever, und der dritte Song war An der schönen blauen Donau. Und dann ... Es hat alles was mit ... Es sind alles Titelsongs von Filmen, die vor 1980 produziert wurden. Man hat gesucht, ein Song im Zweivierteltakt.
Zweivierteltakt sozusagen. Sorry, Zweivierteltakt. Weil der erste Song Mission Impossible ist im Fünffierteltakt komponiert. Die typische, nein, nee, nee, nee, Saturday Night, was ist immer der Song? Staying Alive war es, glaube ich, genau. Der Song, den man auch ... Wenn man Leute am leben halten möchte genau weil man die bpm hält das herz gut zum leben erweckt hahaha staying alive ist klassischer vierviertel-Takt-Song einer schönen blauen Bono und Balzer drei Viertel-Takt und ein Zweiviertel-Takt war gesucht und das habe ich das ist das Niveau auf dem das stattfinden und erraten wenn ich ich sowas erraten würde, ich wäre eine Woche lang glücklich. Ich war kurz glücklich, ja. Und dann denkt man aber auch, holy shit, aber jetzt der Rest war ja nirgends. Ja, super coole Sendung, macht sehr viel Spaß. Schaut euch das an und falls ihr meine Frage beantwortet, freut euch, denn es wird sich nicht so oft wiederholen. Ansonsten können wir natürlich auch gucken, dass wir Bildungsangebote machen, also dass wir für die nächste Woche ein paar Funfacts vorbereiten, ein bisschen was aus dem alten Griechenland, vielleicht aus der versunkenen Stadt Atlantis oder irgendwie sowas in der Richtung oder mathematisches, vielleicht Physik oder sowas. Ja, ich kann mal eben Impulsreferat zu einem mathematischen Thema halten. Finde ich super, finde ich klasse. Okay, alles klar. Lernt ihr auch hier was und dann könnt ihr die Zeiten gut nutzen. Bis dahin habt eine schöne Woche, haut rein. rein. Feiert, feiert schön, was auch immer ihr zu feiern habt.
Feiert, lasst es krachen,
Leute. Macht's gut, bis zum nächsten Mal.
Ich wünsche euch
alles gut. Ich heb ab.
Ich würde noch kurz bedächtig zu allen schauen,
allen kurz in die Augen gucken.
Und so wissend nicken.
So als wäre etwas Unwannsgesprochenes zwischen uns jetzt
geklärt.
Und es ist so, wir sehen uns nächste Woche und es ist allen klar. Kommst du? Ich bin schnell angeschnallt. Ich winke und mache die Tür zu. Setze mich zu dir, leg dir meine Hand auf die Schulter und leg dir auch dir zu, lächelnd. Als wäre irgendwas passiert. Wollen wir? Zum Beispiel 400 Folgen, 400 gemeinsame Folgen. Aber es ist nicht ausgesprochen, es ist nur zwischen uns. Okay, ich verstehe. Und plötzlich realisiere ich das und nimm dir auch zu. Leg deine Hand auf den Steuerknüppel, der den Hyperspace-Turbo-Antrieb startet. Und gemeinsam. Ich lege meine Hand auf deine. Wunderschön. Ich bin nicht angeschnallt, ich bin noch nicht angeschnallt. Okay, dann würde ich kurz warten, bis du dich angeschnallt. Weil ich diesen Moment nicht zerstören will, aber auch grosse Sicherheitsbedenken habe, nehme ich dann umständlich die andere Hand, um nicht diesen Moment zu zerstören, und schnall mich awkward an. Ich lasse dir ein bisschen Raum mit meiner Schulter, ich gehe ein Stück zurück, damit er das Manöver … Ich bewege meine Hand auf deinen Oberschenkel. Okay, ich ziehe meinen Oberschenkel zurück.
Ich sag, Bäume.
Okay, ja.
Ja.
Und wer?
Heber!
Blablabla!
It's a Worst Bird production.